one o' uh we're going to go ahead and
convene uh today's division 3 Finance uh
today is Monday um February 10th today
we will hear uh presentations from the
Department on public health um
developmental services
and elderly and Adult Services and then
if we have time at the end uh or
interest we we might allow public
comment
um who who wants to start from the
Department all right so so let let me
let me tee this up so this has been a
difficult request that I've made of the
department because we're we're so close
to having the governor's budget released
um there was some question of why I
wanted us to meet and and so what I've
I've done is I've U you're the assistant
commissioner or director associate
commissioner associate commissioner okay
congratulations again uh so I I had a
chance to talk to the associate
commissioner about it and I I reiterated
our promise that uh the committee won't
be asking about dollars or numbers of
tees or any kind of Manpower but I I did
ask her to focus on kind of an audit
Trail almost it's not exactly that but
sort of a a history of of the programs
that are in public health now and how
they got there and so and then we're
also going to talk about some contracts
with
UNH right um so so with that uh you're
you're you're welcome to begin thank you
thank you so much so for the record my
name is Patricia Tilly I'm an associate
commissioner here at the Department of
Health and Human Services um thank you
for the opportunity to come and talk to
you a little bit about public health um
I want to give you five things over the
next 60 Minutes or however long this
takes that I hope that will inform your
decision-making as you wrestle through
the budget um I know that you have a lot
of work ahead of you and so these five
things are informed by history
by data and by the needs of your
neighbors your friends and the people
that you represent so here's the five
things that we're going to talk about as
requested from representative Edwards
I'm going to walk through the history
and the authority of Public Health that
led us up to our current organizational
structure pre pandemic and post pandemic
I'm going to highlight where the general
court has historically invested some
general funds in public health no
numbers but I'm going to just sort of
tell you where they are are um I'm going
to describe how the division has
reorganized over that pandemic into its
current configuration and then four um I
am going to transition if time allows
into addressing some of the questions
that we had the last time I was here
when I talked about Behavioral Health
and dcyf to talk about the role of
prevention public health and that
Continuum of dhh H DHHS services and
then five of course is to answer any of
the questions that you have as we go
forward so that's that's my goal as we
go through here so if we jump in um that
second slide we you'll notice that this
is the third time you've seen slide two
and you're going to probably see it
maybe even one more time today and my
conversation today is really going to
focus on the base of this figure that
supports the building of the foundation
of Optimal Health and well-being for
everyone um as we transition into just
the little bit of the history side of
today um you're going to have to indulge
me in a few minutes as we talk a little
bit about where we got here and I'm
going to start you back in
1882 um actually 1881 um it's hard to
believe there was a time when there was
not a Department of Health and Human
Services in the state of New Hampshire
it was actually legislated put into
being in 1881 the first Department was
in place in
1882 and I just want to have you think
about a moment that moment in time and I
actually have the props sitting behind
me I actually have the initial very
first report from the Department of
Health from 1882 used to sit in my
office when I was the director of Public
Health so back at that time and I think
you're going to find some parallels
municipalities and individuals were
navigating industrialization in the
state with new opportunities for work
new opportunities for wealth but some of
that came at a cost at that time
smallpox was running rampant in the
Mills and it was po in up all over the
state and infants and children and
pregnant women were dying from
complications of birth as well as
infectious diseases our Industries
agriculture um and human waste was
actually contaminating the rivers in the
state and our water supplies and our
food and milk was rampant with
adulteration with contaminants in our
food and milk and so that's where the
state legislature said there we need to
do something about that so on SL five
you'll see the opening paragraph from
the first report of the Department of
Health um and this which is now stat um
RSA 1259 so you'll see that opening
statement it is now translated into this
foundational um piece of authorization
which is that the now the commissioner
of the Department of Health and Human
Services shall take cognizant of the
interest of the health and life among
the people and make invest
investigations in qu queries and so that
is what we do today you know you can
speed through and look through at your
time on your own Leisure around SL could
you give me a moment CU I I think I'm on
the wrong okay oh sorry no no that's me
sure so by the time you get to slide six
this also takes you a little bit through
the history where 1901 we set up a
public health laboratory which we still
have today we developed there was
legislation in 1909 that in that allowed
us to have inspector of sorts food and
otherwise 1921 we started talking about
maternal and child health and in 1986 we
specifically carved out communicable
disease all of that provides a
background of where we are today to get
to representative Edward's question on
slide seven which is what did Public
Health look like before the pandemic so
on slide seven you'll see our state
fiscal year 2018 division of Public
Health Services org
chart you'll see um six bureaus I will
give you that we had 250 full-time
authorized positions in for the state
fiscal year
2018 budget we then move into slides um
eight and nine and that describes the
programs how they existed for the 2018
2019 budget um as a reminder you know
most of
question correct the on the on the slide
here do these do these names map into
the activity descriptions yes in the
budget they they're are they map one to
one or are they close um they they are
90% mapping there and as you move into
slides and again this is from 2018 so as
you move move into slides eight and N
they should oh match thank you okay so
as you move into slides eight and N this
is just at a very high level level what
those bureaus mean what the main
programs in each of those bureaus I've
also highlighted where historically
there have been general fund Investments
there are general fund Investments for
maternal and child health mainly as a
match to something called our Title Five
Grant which is the federal funding
another fund history fact it's the
oldest Grant um two states was maternal
and child health um federal grants so
MCH has been around since the
1930s um and morphed into a block grant
as we know it today under the Reagan
Administration so longtime work when it
morphed into a block grant at that time
it was required to have a state general
fund match we have a limited amount of
General funds around child vaccine in um
in our Bureau of infectious disease I'm
I'm sorry I just want to make sure I
understand I'm listening right general
fund match does that mean is this is a
50/50 program or you you don't mean to
be that precise I don't mean to be that
precise for this particular Grant it's
um you have to maintain it's more of a
maintenance of effort so it's a you
maintain the amount that was there when
the grant initially went in so there's a
requirement to have a maintenance of
effort all right to be more precise
thank you for that question all right um
there's a little bit of money in for
infectious disease for childhood vaccine
money in our Public Health laboratory
that's where where the greatest bullus
of General funds are is to maintain that
laboratory that started in 1901 and is
extraordinarily important to this day
and then as we move into slide eight in
food protection and then back in 2018
General funds and our state loan
repayment program so again highlight
that this is where strategic Investments
have been made over time and what the
you you're doing great I and I keep
tripping you up but the state loan
repayment there's deeper slides on this
you'll be more specific about who the
intended beneficiaries of those
repayment programs are I I I don't have
specific slides on the state loan
repayment I'm happy to take questions
and answer them okay so let's just just
hang a a comment off of there it it
would be good to see sort of an
itemization of what kind of Eligibility
there is for state loan repayment sure I
can tell you that off the top of my head
and then we can follow up with
additional information if you would like
so the state loan repayment was designed
to be a state program um that provides
loan educational loan repayment for
health care providers when it was
designed originally many years ago it
was really focused on
Physicians and um and to get them to
rural areas to qualify for the program
you must agree to work in an um an
underserved area often times that's our
federally qualified Health Centers rural
areas or where there's a population
where there's unmet medical need a
medical Ser a a um hit uh I can't
remember the name off the top my head
but underserved areas um the state you
then sign a contract with the state and
we give you three years worth of loan
repayment assuming that you stay working
for those underserved um populations
either either in a federally qualified
Health Center or a hospital we expanded
this program several years ago before
the pandemic to include Behavioral
Health Providers and so quite frankly
the majority of our state loan repayment
right now are for Behavioral Health
Providers down to the Master's level
anyone who is certified to Bill
essentially um can have um Can may have
access to the state loan repayment
program again that they serve
underserved areas so folks like our
community mental health centers are big
users of the state loan repayment for
their staff is there anything else you'd
like just off the top of my
head represent
walner just I wondered if quickly you
could tell us maybe how many uh
providers have received the have been
involved in this loan repayment program
people thanks for the question I can't
tell you the number off the top of my
head we this this program prog has
expanded and contracted over times um we
used some arpa money during the pandemic
so we were able to open up the doors
even wider and not only um attract
additional folks but actually continue
beyond the three years for some we were
able to extend with some of those arpa
funds as well we can get back to you
with the exact number but I can tell you
that the proportion right now is really
in the behavioral health world we still
have some dentists who we we brought on
dental providers and dental hygienists
to match up with the Medicaid um adult
benefit so that we could make sure that
if they were serving a Medicaid
population they would be eligible for
State loan repayment thank you th this
is this is good I I'm learning more
every time I hear this and so the
definition of an underserved area where
the medical need needs to be
provided it would be interesting to um
later to hear
how that analysis is done great there's
a there is a pretty standard analysis
that we use across the country it's
what's used to designate our federally
qualified Health Centers and Rural
Health Centers so it's it's a little bit
complicated I can't rattle it off the
top of my head but there is um an
analysis that we use from the federal
government to determine medically
underserved
areas representative nvan call yes Mr
chairman uh you said that predominantly
the shift is a followup to
representative walner question that the
the split on who is uh this the growth
in this has been predominantly in the
behavioral uh Health Providers yes
roughly ballpark this so the split as
you see it 8020 5050 it's actually
probably close to 8020 right
now and and mainly because we've
expanded to the types of providers so
that we have Masters
clinicians as opposed to when slurp was
sort of first imagined which was really
thinking about Physicians um the good
news about getting down to that Master's
level group is that we can serve more
people uh the proport the dollar amount
that we give for loan repayment is built
into our system so we give more money to
Physicians and dentists who have higher
medical or dental school bills then
someone who is at a master's level who
has um who has some loan repayment but
it's at a lesser level and so we
proportionately give a a smaller amount
to Folks at that Master's level versus
the MD or DMD level so one one quick
followup so you know not to get into
specific numbers but so the split on the
total number of providers roughly 8020
if you looked at the financial split
would that um and given the explanation
just gave would that significantly alter
that so we um so what I will say is just
to reiterate we're able to serve more
people with at the lower level of of
clinicians I don't mean that but it's
sort of that mid level of clinician we
can serve more people because we can
make the money spread a little bit
farther okay thank you
y represent
Daniels thank you uh looking at the 2018
structure are any of those programs
mandated by the federal government
so that that's a great question I think
um many um you know roughly especially
in 2018 about 85% of the funds for the
division of Public Health were federal
funds or sometimes other funds but you
know that's roughly been the split 85
federal or other and then 15% General
funds um so by mandated we have grants
for each of those so we do that work I
would have to get back to you of exactly
what if there were any federal
requirement for any one of those
programs but I can tell you that they're
mostly Fally
funded okay and and just beond on the
the other research are there any
mandates that have been placed upon us
that are not funded thank you I don't
believe there are at this time
thank representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question can you
speculate why there has has been a raise
in the number of behavior
health needs in this state is this
because of the post pandemic and you
know thank thank you representative P
Pierce that um PRI um that's the
million-dollar question isn't it right
now and if we have time today I you know
I have a little bit I have a few slides
here really talking about the base of
some of those Behavioral Health needs
especially as you think about the
experiences that children go through
something called adverse childhood
experiences there's that component
there's also lots of components around
issues of the concrete supports families
need the stressors that have been on
them that was certainly exacerbated by
the pandemic so I can get to that
later to uh nail down representative
Daniel's question a little bit more uh I
I hear you that we receive federal funds
correct and when we accept the federal
funds we're uh accepting the mandates
that go with them so so I think the
distinction that I we we need to have is
is those programs that were required by
federal statute to have and those that
we basically opt into because we opted
to take the Grant I i' I'd like to be
able to understand that DeMark Nathan's
going to talk a little bit more about
that sure so um good afternoon members
of the committee Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer of Department of
Health and Human Services one really
important thing that I just want to
remind this committee about before we
get too deep in the weeds today is that
we right now we are preparing all of the
house presentations and many of you will
probably remember I think representative
Mooney referred to it as the coloring
books that we bring um we'll be bringing
those back again and within those we go
through every Bureau and every account
in the programs and we also have these
documents called budget briefing books
uh and for each one of those uh accounts
that are over a million dollars we
include what are the outputs what are
the deliverables what are the federal
requirements what are the different
funding sources is there a match is
their maintenance of effort and so we'll
be providing those books this is part of
the challenge between having these
discussions before the governor's budget
comes out so I just kind of want to
highlight that and and have that in the
back of all the members mind that we
will have that documentation for you
here um and and that's prepped and ready
but we just need the governor's budget
to come out so we can start to get into
those numbers and some of these specific
questions thank you thank you so if you
slide to um slide 10 please this is the
org chart that director Ian watt is
going to be presenting exactly during
those budget hearings right now this is
the this is the constellation of
programs within the divisional Public
Health Services as of today and you'll
see a couple things we have reorganized
some bureaus we moved from bureaus to
seven and that is because we've had uh
the Emergency Services Unit which was
which is now called The Bureau of
emergency preparedness response and
resilience um but it's important to note
that within this new structure this new
or chart we still roughly have the same
number of full-time authorized positions
again we're going to talk more about
that when you have your budget
presentation but while this looks like a
big shift in reality we are moving some
of the
pieces around to make more
organizational sense especially over the
course of the pandemic so if you look um
to slide 11 here's the things that have
t stayed the same our Bureau of
laborator our laboratory our Bureau of
infectious disease public health
statistics and informatics and the
Bureau of Public Health protection they
are largely the same as they were in
2018 so good news all of that we have
been doing that work for a long time
time it is roughly stayed the same even
through the pandemic as we exploded in
temporary staff those numbers have also
come back down to pre-pandemic levels so
you saw this but our full-time
authorized has stayed flat during that
entire time so let's get into a little
bit more detail of what moved where so
if on slide 12 you want to take a look
at the first thing that you'll Note pre
pandemic 2018 we had some something
called The Bureau of population and
Community Health and in that Bureau was
our maternal and child health programs
our Wick programs all of our chronic
disease programs and our tobacco
programs at that time in 2018 that
Bureau had more contracts in it than any
other division in the Department of
Health and Human Services it was a a
large number of federal grants and a
large number of community engagement and
community
um Partnerships so for that reason it
made sense to split it in half the span
of control was too wide in that program
and we needed to have the expertise that
could really manage and the leadership
to manage those so we split it in half
into a bureau of family health and
nutrition and a bureau of prevention and
wellness family health and nutrition is
essentially what was maternal and child
health and Wick prevention and wellness
is all of our vast array of chronic
disease prevention programs and tobacco
that's how those two things were split
you'll see in a minute that we've added
a couple of other things into the Bureau
of prevention and wellness so that's a
big exchange so no net new really we
were just sort of going from one to
other splitting it in a half the next
thing as I mentioned earlier we had our
Emergency Services Unit which was
located in our commissioner's office
before the pandemic mainly so that it
could provide Provide support for any
emergency response across the department
the pandemic happened and the Emergency
Services Unit essentially um was
deployed in many ways to the division of
Public Health Services to help with that
response the Emergency Services Unit was
responsible for putting on those big
vaccine events the events that were at
the racetrack our blizzard booster Blitz
all of that was done by our emergency
what was then the Emergency Services
Unit and because of the alignment
between public health and their work it
made sense to just move it all within
the organizational structure of Public
Health to keep those lines of
communication good and also the lines of
responsibility um also so that part and
parcel just moved over to
dphs to this day it makes a ton of sense
um they help us on all sorts of
responses from you may recall we had a
measles outbreak in the Upper Valley
this summer we've had Legionella even
even this past week you may have seen in
the news that we've had a case of
something called empo they help us dayto
day and are very tightly connected with
um our infectious disease program I'm
sorry I it says emergency but do they
also take standard missions like uh when
the start of school shows up do they
help coordinate uh vaccine programs for
no it's really about emergency events
they also have a responsibility to work
with Homeland Security so there are
those of you who are familiar with the
way Homeland Security works there are
these things called essential functions
esfs um and so they manage housing and
health and wellness so they have a foot
over a connect sort of a dotted line
over to hscm so a different way that
isn't necessar seems directly related to
Public Health when we had the eclipse
last spring they were deployed to make
sure that we had first aid um available
in all the areas in the in the North
Country when we had that Rush of you
know tens of thousands of people so
those are the sorts of things they work
you uh I have a I have a quick question
so uh this is staffed for emergencies
but is it a Flexible Staffing uh
situation or I mean if you don't have an
if you don't have a that's getting a
little close to where we're not talking
money or man I'm not talking money I'm
just talking I can answer that I can
answer it quickly it is a fixed step
and then we have volunteers that Flex as
we need them okay thank you so because
we're always mindful um if you go to
slide 13 of not expanding our footprint
too much um so you'll know that we split
that one big Bureau population Health
Community Services split that in half we
added ESU and so we reduced something we
eliminated what was then a bureau of
Public Health policy systems and
performance we eliminated that Bureau
and realigned those programs into
existing bureaus so we took the office
of rural health and primary care and the
state loan repayment program put that in
the Bureau of prevention and wellness we
took therapeut our therapeutic cannabis
program some quality improvement work
our legislative liaison and put them
directly under our deputy director at
the division of Public Health so we just
moved the deck chairs a little bit to
balance span of control um to make sure
that there was an e uh an equitable lift
Chiefs so then you will move into slide
um uh 14 so those are that's th those
were the bureaus that's how that
structure went from six to seven bureaus
mainly because we added that Emergency
Services Unit we split one Bureau and
then eliminated another so that's how
you got from six in in 2018 to seven
currently there's also important to note
as you do think about the funding again
when we go through our budget pres
presentation in a few weeks we moved
some programs as well one of those was
the prescription drug monitoring program
that was in the office of professional
lure and
certification um I C uh around 2018 I
could go back and find the date the
legislature moved that Authority into
public health so they are now nestled in
that Bureau of prevention and wellness
as well so pdmp came over there are no
General funds associated with that but
just for your knowledge that's just
moved in there and then two areas where
we do have General funds are two
programs called comprehensive child
family supports and services cfss you'll
sometimes see that as and support for
our Family Resource Centers these were
funded in the division for economic
security at some point even prior to
2018 that were funded out of DCF they
now live in the division of Public
Health Services so th that money moved
with them and traveled with with the
programs General funds into the division
of Public Health it was budgeted in
other areas of the department before
there great so that's that's all I have
for just the organization you'll see um
again when we talk about the budget
you'll see how there are some increases
in general funds but mainly that's
because of some of these moving parts
that just moved from one part of the
department into this part of the
department representative Edwards had
had some questions around UNH contract
so I can talk about them right now okay
I'm I'm I'm I'm just looking to make
sure I can map later the accounting uh
activity descriptions with your slide
deck sure and and so with without
looking too closely like I see
Administration down there on 5131
8579 those two towards the bottom are
are they written up in your slide deck
here oh are you look I'm sorry what you
okay so I got an Insider's copy of um of
an abstract of the accounting units
for it did it get emailed to all of you
no at this point I've only shared sh it
with you and representative Mooney
because we were the only ones who talked
about it this morning but I have copies
that I can hand out to the committee if
you like yeah could you
yeah thank you um so so I'm I'm just I'm
just going to want to be able to go down
the lists and know which one is which on
the activity descriptions sure so so it
it it depends if if we're referring to
an activity or an accounting unit
generally speaking though most of those
should map and when we do when we do our
presentations we will have the bureau
and accounting detail and we'll be
covering all of all of the various
functions of each area so there will be
a tie back to that during those
presentations that'll be very clear
perfect thank you thank you um so let's
talk about UNH you had some questions
representative Edwards around division
of public Health's partnership with you
I I I did I understand we have four
contracts they've been around for a
while they're they're they are plan to
continue I don't want to talk about
dollar amounts sure so if you look at
slide 15 I have two of those four
contracts um the two that are not there
I'll start with that um one is a
contract that has not moved forward so
we we just took it off the list because
it's not current right now the second of
the two that you don't see we had a
contract with the University of New
Hampshire for a fellowship essentially a
um a graduate level intern over the
summer so I did not include that just
because of the transient nature of that
was just for that internship for a UNH
Fellowship for the summer they worked on
our food Protection Program they were
great but it was very time Limited in
less than
$10,000 the two main contracts that we
have though and we are continuing are
our maternal and child health
epidemiologist so for almost 20 years
now we have been working with UNH to
have a PhD level um uh Professor who is
expert in data analysis and maternal and
child health partner with the division
of Public Health to do the complex and
sophisticated data analyses that are
required in order to look at the health
of moms babies and kids um this has been
a really extraordinary partnership over
the time we it allows us to get again
PhD highlevel sophisticated analysis
access and um in order so that we can do
this sort of program planning and
evaluation that we need to do to make
sure that we're making good choices
about where we put programs what we
invest in and not only does this help
the division of Public Health Services
it's also been really helpful for
Medicaid to have somebody who
understands not only the data part of it
but also the programming and the content
around maternal and child health to get
those two someone with those two pieces
of knowledge together typically they are
in an academic environment so that's
been a great contract we we look forward
to continuing it so so on that I'm I'm
looking down at the bottom uh of the of
that column and it says to help the
department make datadriven decisions to
improve health outcomes for mothers and
babies yes so I understand the theory
but would you be able to give specific
examples at the right time to to show us
the the the connection between all this
great work being done in the academic
area and how it's translated to changing
patients lives sure we happy to do that
in depth at at some other time I can
give you one example right now
postpartum coverage um the general court
was very generous in the past sessions
to extend postpartum care to on for
women on Medicaid to 12 months the data
analysis of that was done in part by
this maternal and child health
epidemiologist okay because in my life
I've seen really great reports that
don't do anything because nobody takes
the information and does something with
it and so I don't want to be building
beautiful documentation that doesn't
really matter to people I appreciate
that we use it to determine where we um
put our services um so uh for prenatal
care or to highlight there was once a
time where we did teen pregnancy
prevention programs and we use the data
from this epidemiologist to pick the
areas in the state where would that
would be most effective not only where
the teen birth rates were high but where
there were other contributing factors
we've done that for other programs as
well when we need to we only have a
limited set of dollars and we want to
focus them on where they're going to
impact we use our MCH super thank you
sure and so the other piece um that we
the other contract that we have in
public health right now is for the
Pediatric Mental Health Care Access
program these are federal dollars from
CDC that help um us connect providers to
Providers and we're going to talk about
it a little bit at the end of my
presentation as well but at a very short
level
uh or a very high level um the
University of New Hampshire does
something called project Echo and that's
where they do training for providers on
a number of different topics and so we
have contracted with them to do training
with pediatricians Primary Care
Providers to get to help them understand
what they need to know from child
psychiatry because as I talked about
last time we were here the pediatrician
really is the front line when we're
talking about Behavioral Health and so
it connects p pediatricians with
psychiatrists and they do some cross-
Level Training and also does some really
interesting um teleconsult visits so yes
I I didn't want to interrupt you I just
thought you were about done um okay so
so I can see the Practical value of this
but as I see it um it it feels to me
like this should be more of a temporary
transitional program because it's
essentially doing what uh
professionals do anyways they they have
continuing medical education programs
they have societies that tell them what
they need to know and what's the Hot
Topic they they they provide some
resources the telec consultation is a
new media relatively for them to be able
to cross talk with each other and so I
see uh this in its stable state to be
kind of the natural Order of Things
without a requirement for an explicit uh
State driven
program that's that's my thought so do
you want to comment on that sure so it's
a federally funded um program from CDC I
don't know how long you know and by that
nature it's temporary you know we have a
five-year Grant and we do the work and
then CDC decides what they want to fund
moving forward and we decide if it still
makes sense for us so it is time Limited
in that way and so we have been using
the past couple years to stand up the
program build the cohorts of providers
someone's got to coordinate all that but
is this going to be in place 10 15 years
from now you know I would suggest
probably not we will probably be doing
something else by that time is is there
a share with General funds in this you
may men federal funds this all 100%
Federal yep okay thank you great are
there questions representative
Daniels thank you in raising children I
understand that there are always times
where Behavior yeah comes into play so
how does one determine when a
psychiatrist is needed that's a great
question thank you and I'm not a
provider so you know you're going to get
the non-clinical answer for that but in
this particular program we know that um
moms and babies tend to show up at those
well child visits through childhood and
parents will describe behaviors that are
concerning there are validated screening
tools and so part of what this program
does is make sure that those Primary
Care Providers those you know
pediatricians their regular pediatrician
have the tools they need to help
determine what's regular behavior and
what might be something that's more
concerning and so you know they use
their clinical expertise as well as
these standardized evidence-based
screenings to help make those decisions
and then um provide the referrals when
needed much like you know I would I
would frame that much like when you know
those of us who are older go to the
doctor and say we might you know my
blood pressure might be raising and they
will make that decision through their
series of clinical assessment and
screening tools of when you need to go
to a Cardiologist versus being just
treated at your primary care provider
it's same thing okay I guess my my my
concern all it it almost sounds like
you're trying to fit every child into
the same box and and we obviously know
that children are different from one
another 100% And that's really the
that's the art of the clinical work is
to understand what's within the normal
range of development and all kids
develop differently along the way and
what could eventually be something that
um requires more intensive care so I I
agree with you 100% kids are all come
they're all unique but um the clinicians
are trained in their medical practice to
understand what's within the bounds of
normal or expected or typical and then
what might need additional
care represent toski thank you I just
have a quick question and this is just
uh something I'm curious about as I'm
thinking about it my children are all in
their young 20s and so over the course
of a decade as they went through their
Primary Care visits um there was an
introduction partway through um with my
middle child and younger child of like a
screening tool on depression anxiety
which my older child didn't get is that
something that would have come through
your department to implement that or is
that more of like training from National
Best Practices uh both 100% so certainly
best practices would inform that um AAP
the American Academy of Pediatrics
certainly takes a position on what
really is the the best practice they
have something called anticipatory
guidance for pediatricians where all the
smart pediatricians get together and say
this is what you should be talking of
every one of those well visits and these
are the sort of tools you should use the
way division of Public Health supports
that is to provide additional training
where needed at times and also to set
expectations sometimes for um for
community health centers that may
receive specific funding from the
division to say oh yeah there's that
developmental screen we would have an
expectation that you do developmental
screening at these particular Milestones
thank you very much great okay so um the
rest of your presentation looks like a
good subject matter material for us to
be smarter in public health um would
would you be able to um summarize and
hit the high points and make your main
points in like 10 minutes or less I will
do my best thank you that's a lot of
slides but we I I can do that for you
I'll I'll give you a heads up on 23 yes
uh you have these arrows connecting to
one another Y and what I'd like to know
uh when you get there is uh are those
are those arrows they it makes it appear
as though they're all full and intacted
and everything's working like a machine
sure it I'd like the little Nuance
beyond Behind that we can get to that
what needs to be built what is broken
you know all right thank you thank you I
really appreciate that so I'm going to
fly through and I'm always happy to take
questions on this later on I appreciate
the need to get out of here early today
so where we're starting on slide 17 and
again you can take a look at this at
your own time there's something there's
an idea of something called adverse
childhood experiences and these are
experiences um such as abuse and neglect
some household challenges that have been
found to correlate with some negative
health effects as people become adults
so if a child experiences physical abuse
emotional neglect has household
challenges of a family member
incarcerated you know um a parent who is
the treated violently through domestic
violence there was a a study a landmark
study of over 18,000 adults in the
Kaiser Permanente um Health Group uh
that when studied those with some of
these negative Health outcomes mental
health concerns risk-taking Behavior
substance use even higher risk for HIV
infectious disease and chronic disease
even heart attacks can be traced back in
some way to um the more of these adverse
childhood experiences you have the more
likely that you might have some of these
negative health effects I present this
here simply because it's the the reason
and the rationale for a public health
approach that these are not just
individual one-offs that in general
there appears to be some robust um
correlation between these experiences
that happen to children and adult health
and adult Behavior this also has a
generational effect as you have parents
who may have experienced these things as
children who were then parenting their
own children so in New Hampshire these
adverse childhood you know experiences
are incredibly common you know over 64%
of females in high school almost 50% of
high school boys report at least one of
those adverse childhood experiences as
you look at that list that makes sense
there are things on there like divorce
absolutely they may have experienced one
of those as adults we also know that
about six out of 10 adults have also
experienced one or more of those adverse
childhood experiences but the where the
rubber hits the road is when you
experience a lot of them that's when the
city
effect happens more adverse childhood
experiences higher risk of negative
Health outcomes so if you have an Aces
score they're called aces of five to
eight so if you look at that list if you
check off five to eight of those things
it indicates a significantly higher risk
for developing a range of physical and
mental health conditions later in life
including depression substance use
chronic disease heart disease Cancer and
a shortened lifespan so when we look at
where our teens are today we see about
one and five have between three and four
aces and then a much smaller number to
um represented Daniel's Point who might
have had a lot of those experiences and
oftentimes those are kids that have
likely come through our division for
children youth and families or her are
needing to access highly specialized um
behavioral health programs so I'll skip
over public Health's role in that but
it's really because the reason reason
Public Health gets its nose in this
business is because we want to prevent
those those long adult um outcomes we
also don't want any kids to be suffering
as well but we have a role in preventing
chronic disease behavioral health
problems substance use so what can you
do about that I think that that's a
question that I know that others have
asked and there's a thing also you have
adverse childhood experiences those are
all the negative things that could have
happened to you but you pair that with
something that I think is even more
strong and that is our protective
factors and so all of us can think in
our minds of a person or a family who
had a lot of horrible things happen to
them as a kiddo and yet they've sort of
come through that with Incredible
strength and resiliency and oftentimes
what you can match that back to is some
accumulation of these five protective
factors around having social emotional
competence you can recognize and deal
with your emotions you have knowledge of
parenting and Child Development again if
you're a parent if you learn about
parenting even if your experience as a
child was less than optimal but if you
learn and grow into understanding the
best ways to parent to in order to
support your child that's a protective
Factor social connections we talked
about this last time you can't you know
I if you're isolated whether you're a
young parent or an older adult we know
that puts you at higher risk for all
sorts of negative Health outcomes and
then of course the end of the day there
are those concrete supports do you have
housing do you have health insurance do
you have food on the table all of that
if you've got those things it helps to
make you and a family more resilient and
so this is where public health comes in
with some of those programs you know you
can flip to page 22 or slide 22 and you
see that triangle that I shared the last
time again we spend a lot of money right
now on those individuals that have this
really high need for services and we
spend that money in residential care
there is a suggestion and I think data
to to support this that if you rightsize
that triangle and spend more time again
if you think about a parent who had
those negative adverse childhood
experiences in their childhood who were
now taking care of a new baby if you
spend the little time talking about um
building connections building parenting
skills you have an opportunity to
interrupt that gener erational
pattern so so I'm getting to your slide
may may I I think uh representative PRI
had a question but I I I I want to for
transparency to the public I I just want
to say that uh it's my and you can
correct me um what I want to say is that
uh we are looking at a current situation
where we invest heavily in sort of the
high-end uh more expensive uh
um interaction with providing care and
the theory is that if we had invested
differently and we had put more money
into prevention that we would have saved
money on the back end and so uh so to
the extent that there's a proposal to
shift resources the challenge that we're
going to have in this budget year is you
still need the money to take care of the
people in desperate need
and then you would need to find new
money to be investing in the preventive
side and I think in this particularly
budget challenged year or two years
that's going to be very difficult for us
to be able to really do that and and
this this these ideas represented here I
think are very good very solid but I I
just keep uh hitting the Dilemma of of
how we're going to do both things with
the same dollar and and so
I representative priest that was more
commentary than anything because I I Am
I Wrong do you I think the challenge in
front of you is to look at the pie that
you have right now and determine how
you're going to spend that understanding
there aren't going to be more resources
and so where do you strategically invest
it is the challenge that comes every two
years as you build a budget and I
appreciate that this year is going to be
particularly difficult but my um what I
would suggest is as we think about it if
you pull from one string to balance
something up here is there may be
unintended consequences later on it is a
challenge always in a banian budget
because you may realize those costs may
come later and they're not going to come
in this this bium so that's why you all
are smart and at the table and you put
together your budgets understanding that
so so I I do hear you I think we are
smart but but this is an this is an
environment where experience really
matters and having walked the trenches
with your boots on the ground you have
information that we and knowledge and
insight that we'll never have and so so
we're going to have to rely on you to to
tell us where the strings are yes okay
uh representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question it goes back to slide 17 when
you break down down the adverse
childhood experiences and the one in
particular household challenges um
shouldn't there have been um a circle
emphasis in the environmental lead
poisoning as being very significant
because if a child has lead poisoning
his
whole mental
growth yeah I fully appreciate and we
have and this um general court has been
very supportive around lead poisoning
initiatives over time and I I can't
overstate how important that is in a
state like New Hampshire where we have
such a significant number of homes built
before 1970 and quite frankly many of
those that are in substandard conditions
so that paint is available so it was not
part of this study I I could spend some
time thinking about that because this
was based out of California that does
not have quite the same lead exposure
risk that we do here in the Northeast
just because the age of our
so represent tki I this is sort of
somewhat connected to that I was
expecting to see um a circle that said
poverty and how the interconnectedness
of poverty for families and I just don't
know how that comes into discussing Aces
or not typically it hasn't um I mean I
think it comes in when we talk about
protective factors really that's where
we we see the impact of poverty and
whether some of those impacts can be um
mitigated by food housing you know
access to tanif access to snap access to
Wick that's where we can see that if
those needs are met we have a better
chance of making sure that um families
are more stable and the children
ultimately are more independent of those
Social Services great thank you that
helps representative PRI uh going along
with the previous question oh excuse me
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um going along with
the previous speaker's question um I
also agree that poverty needs to be
emphasized given the fact that there has
been a rise of homelessness in our major
cities and all of our communities and it
has definitely affected the um the
childhood Absolut absolutely and again a
protective Factor when you've got those
basic you know those of you studied
maso's hierarchy of needs you've got to
have that basic set need of your housing
and your food and you've got to have
that stable so that you can do the
emotional regulation and the hard work
that is parenting as any of you who are
sitting here who are parents know it's a
hard enough job regardless but if you
don't know where your next meal is
coming from it becomes that much harder
so if we
y represent Daniels thank you uh what is
your success rate of your protective fa
factors overcoming uh Aces versus people
remaining dependent on the government
sure so um you know we know that um
programs and we can talk about that
actually right now on slide 23 programs
like home visiting there are some
outcomes around there that if once
people have these home visiting programs
where a trained person usually someone
from the community comes in and talks
about parenting connects people with
Services we know that there are fewer
you know um I'm going to look at here
their better birth outcomes so that's P
first of all great because that's less
money to Medicaid if you have a better
birth outcome you have um kids are going
to their health screenings um parents
are better able to cope with stress
better that they're more likely to
enroll in school the parents are more
likely to enroll in school training and
so that gets to those protective factors
that ultimately sets that whole family
up for Independence at the end of the
day especially is you want to make sure
that both kids are attending school and
that the parents are getting the either
the school or the training they need so
that they can be independent thank you
so as we look at slide 23 we've got five
programs here and and I I um they are
part of a system which is like that
little ch ch train of of arrows because
this is the the Family Support programs
that are within the division of Public
Health Services um a reminder back to
that 2018 time some of these were in
other areas of the department they're
now all nestled together organized under
part Public Health in partnership with
the division of children youth and
families and our division for um
Behavioral Health and we have five one
is our family connection center this is
funded by General funds and this
supports families um where a parent is
incarcerated um and so there are Family
Resource Centers built into the state um
men's and women's presence and this
enables connections between that um
individual who is incarcerated that
resident of the correctional system and
their children because we know many
times those family those moms and dads
are going to leave Corrections they're
not most of the time they're not there
for the rest of their lives and they're
going to be a part of that child's life
going forward and so you want to
optimize the ability for them to be an
appropriate parent and part of that is
building that connection so if you think
back to that Aces list a parent
incarcerated really can put kids on a
trajectory can be one of those adverse
childhood experiences that have really
strong impacts on that intergeneration
of mental Behavioral Health substance
use and risk-taking behavior so if you
can come in right then um while mom or
dad is incarcerated and build that
connection and teach some healthy
parenting while they're um incarcerated
that can be really helpful when they go
back even if they don't ever go back or
even if they no longer even have full
custody of their child Simply Having a
relationship ship is helpful and that
looks like reading bedtime like
recording bedtime stories um it looks
like having FaceTime visits and so these
funds help that happen we have our home
visiting program which is really one of
our Flagship programs for um Pro
providing support for children and
famili young families we have a healthy
families America program it's all over
the state it's very evidence informed
both nationally and locally and we can
track the evaluation um it serves a
smaller relatively smaller number of
families because it's pretty intensive
you enroll while you're pregnant and
it's Vol completely voluntary but you
enroll while you're pregnant and you
have um a home visitor who does parent
education with you until your child is
three so it's not a oneandone that's an
ongoing relationship um very effective
the um the general court added hb2 money
to add our to our ability to serve more
families um in the last bium we have
child and family health ports which is
like home visiting and often uses the
modality of Home visiting someone goes
out to somebody's home but this is
really more episodic in nature and
really is designed to meet needs when
they need them um and is highly
connected to our division for children
youth and families um and our Family
Resource Centers and this uses a mix of
federal funds and a little bit of
General funds we have something called
kinship Navigator as we all know we've
got more and I talked about last week we
have more and more families grandparents
ants and uncles others taking care of
kids that are in the dcyf system this
kinship Navigator is a person who can
help that me that family member navigate
what it's like to have a kid when they
you know again grandparents it's been a
long time since any of us had a little
kid in the house helps them navigate
systems that is supported by federal and
general funds and then finally we have
our Family Resource Centers located all
over the the state that coordinate some
of these efforts and are a place for
families to have that kind of parenting
education and build the connections that
they need so that they can be stronger
parents and that is generally supported
by General funds so I've I've gone over
my 10 minutes um there are slides that
talk about these programs a little bit
more in detail if you want to learn more
about them um but at the end of the day
what I really wanted to leave you with
is this notion um of you know across the
department we are working very hard in
my role as an associate commissioner
between dcyf public health behavioral
health is to coordinate all these
efforts so that we can align prevention
we can centralize places to call for
help whether that's your pediatrician's
office or something much higher needed
also for even the pediatricians
themselves um we want to make sure that
we have our helpful services at the
appropriate scale so while we serve 300
families in that intensive home visiting
program is that enough when you think
about the number of families that could
could be served we want to strengthen
supports that families stay that kids
and families stay home I want to reduce
the Reliance on residential care it's
one of our key um initiatives is to
reduce that Reliance it's too expensive
and it's not always great for kids um
it's better for kids to be in families
where it's cheaper and they have the
sort of social emotional support that
they need and again our job is also to
coordinate expert care and finally
measure progress to see if any of this
works so you need the data to in order
to measure progress I have gone over my
time a lot of time no you said an hour
it's been less than an hour so you did
good so uh representative is this uh the
associate commissioner wants to step
away from the table you have a question
yeah I have a I have a quick question
and that is on that chart what are the
trend lines look like in each one of
these in in each one of these arrows so
so there's several questions like that
that maybe we can address by looking at
what you're putting in the coloring book
yes thank you and could you refer to the
exact slide that you're you're pointing
I'm looking at slide 23 it gives
specific numbers for how many and so I'm
interested in what the trend lines have
looked like in each one of those boxes
up down flat super thank you and I'm I'm
sorry because I'm I'm not familiar with
a coloring book since this is my first
term so I it doesn't exist it's it's
it's my nickname for a beautiful
presentation they put together with
tremendous information in it it it's
it's a derogatory term out of huge
difference to the work and quality of it
I was just wondering whether I should
bring my cray own crayons so it never
hurts I can't afford to give you any and
right now I don't know if we can afford
to give you color copies anymore so you
enjoy it while you have them yeah so uh
represent of Mooney just with regards to
those coloring books the complete set of
hard copies is in my office anyone is
welcome to come in and see them and also
they are online the LBA tab on the
legislative website under last year's or
last term's budget the full complete set
is scanned in so a few ways to access
those and they're very carefully well
done thank you thank
you um representative string I just just
a clarification those are last terms
coloring books correct not the ones
we'll get this week that is
correct Mr
chairman represent Daniels yes first of
all thank you so much for the
presentation a lot of good information
here one thing I would have liked to
seen a little bit more of since you you
want to focus more on the preventive
side when we take a look at slide 17 in
the uh the different things of abuse
neglect household challenges I'd be
interested to know how you're planning
on addressing those because I think
that's what you're trying to accomplish
is to stop those so it never gets into
the system but I didn't see a whole lot
on the preventive so I I think um and
part of that is a little rush for time
but those home visiting programs in
particular are designed to reduce entry
in the child welfare system so that's
one example that child and family health
supports again is designed to reduce
entry into that child welfare system and
there's a little bit of data I think let
me look at the slide if I added it
um uh so if you look at slide 26 you can
see in the child um and family U
comprehensive family support systems
that of the 1700 kids discharged from
that program in 21 um 76% had not had an
accepted investigation in three years
that's where the that's where the proof
you know that's where the rubber hits
the road is those programs now we can
never say fully it was that program but
that gives us encouragement that those
sorts of things help keep kids out of
the system in the first place I I guess
what I'm looking for and maybe there's
something online that I can look at to
to say that a home visit is going to do
something I have no idea what happens in
that home visit I would love to take you
on one someday if you'd like but we can
we can provide more information again
just given the time I didn't want to
dive too deeply but we would love to
spend more time talking about those
because it's really again a good
investment early on um to keep kids out
of the front door we talk about you know
the front door door of dcyf this is keep
keeping kids out in the yard far away
from entering into the system and that's
what we want more of good thank
you all right I think you're done with
our questions for now so thank you so
much appreciate it thank you and thank
you for the opportunity to talk about
this I'm always happy to talk more
offline all right um so who wants to go
next
oops I'm here I'm not graceful so that
is one thing you will learn about me um
good afternoon I'm Chris santanello I am
also an associate commissioner here at
the Department of Health and Human
Services I was originally supposed to
present with associate commissioner
Tilly about a week and a half ago but um
I ended up being ill so I appreciate the
opportunity um to follow um Trisha
today want me to I'm just gonna just get
into it okay so I um want if you look on
slide two we have a little bit of an
agenda here we're going to first talk
about developmental Services then go
into healthy aging then discussed our
home and communitybased waivers and then
a little bit on financing for choices
for Independence and Nursing Facility so
how how much time do you think you need
how much time would you like me to need
well I'm just curious you've got this in
your head how much if you just when I
practiced this yesterday I needed 33
minutes but that wasn't with any
questions right those questions darn
questions so is this the only
presentation today after after this this
is it right so okay so you're on I'm on
and what I thought I would do is maybe
go through each section and then at the
end of each section pause to see if
there's questions cuz if that works for
you that okay so this um next slide
you're going to see um a similar slide
associate commissioner Tilly used it a
little while ago um we used it again
when we met a week and a half ago and
then when we did the department overview
and it's just really showing how we meet
the needs across the lifespan today I'm
going to focus on older adults and some
of our specialized populations I think
one of the things within our department
as we have talked about here we are a
large department but yet we're able to
leverage and connect individuals and
seamlessly So within developmental
Services is that okay if I keep on going
okay um I've been with the department
since
2016 prior to that I actually worked in
the developmental Services System for
over 25 years and I think that brings a
Advantage um within the department
because I understand the history of that
system the
complexities the people served and most
importantly um the people that serve
them so I think that brings a um a good
perspective to us here within the
department you will see on the next
slide it's Slide Five
the operating structure of Developmental
services and I think it's important um
as we begin talking about um the
different Services System that you
understand um how the system operates
this is a little bit different than the
last time um we presented to the budget
because we did have a change on July 1st
2023 with how we operate but if you look
in your leftand corner all of our fund
we get um funding from the federal
government through the center of
Medicare and medicate services and it is
a 5050 match we use 50% General funds to
get 50% Federal dollar those funds flow
to the Department of Health and Human
Services we work together closely with
our 10 area agencies we have 10 area
agencies throughout the state they are
private nonprofit organizations and
they're designated um through the
department they actually um provide with
DHHS a shared governance for the system
we um work together for Quality
initiatives and also through the area
agencies they determine eligibility
under
171a so if people apply for services
that is done through their local area
agency
in turn we have service coordinators and
their role is to assist individuals and
families with um accessing services that
meet the needs and the desires of that
person and then in turn we have provider
agencies that provide many of the Direct
Services what is unique is the provider
agencies must be enrolled as a Medicaid
provider um and have the option to Bill
directly for services an agency whether
it's a service provider or an area
agency can provide Direct Services they
can also provide Service Coordination
they just cannot do it for the same
person so that's very different than how
the system used to
be okay so you we you say we have 10
area agencies and they've been
designated by
DHHS so the the first time people hear
that they may think well we got 10
counties we have 10 area agencies but
the the the correlation isn't exact
right correct right so so so that gets
me to the question uh why 10 is is 10 a
magical number and would we save money
if it were seven so there used to be 12
and back in
around 2004 2006 we went from 12 to 10
um and I think you and I have had this
conversation a little bit if we um went
from 10 to 7 I don't think you would
redo have there would be any savings it
would be very minimal
because area agencies are paid through a
designated area agency rate and that is
based on the individual receiving
services so that would continue
regardless as to how many agencies you
had good good answer so Serv service
coordinators um do we have a an
approximate number of how many service
coordinators we we work with it feels
like 8090 something no there's about
8090 service providers there's less
Service Coordination
agencies o okay and and that the number
of service coordinators probably doesn't
have a direct budget impact because it
the the money money that pays them is
basically built into the fees that are
being transferred we we have a rate for
Service Coordination we have a separate
Medicaid rate for that so correct right
so if somebody's looking just grossly at
how we can make this more efficient
changing the number of area agencies
trying to change the number of service
coordinators this would have very little
impact very little impact okay and it
could do some harm right if you yes take
capacity out of the system 100% okay and
then what tell the provider agencies
tell tell us again or tell me again what
what we mean by a provider so that would
be somebody who provides the direct
service they could provide day Services
supported employment some of them
provide residential services so it's the
it's the services that is outlined in
someone's service agreement the service
provider is the one that would provide
that all right thank you you're welcome
any questions there no okay um so next
I'm going to turn over to our road map
um and one of our goals under commitment
to under promote thriving communities is
to strengthen the developmental Services
System um I'm going to on the next slide
I'm going to talk a little bit about
where we've been but this is where we
want to be going and really if you look
at the the middle part of the Circle you
see an individual and they have outcomes
and and what the values we ascribe to
within the system are Choice uniformity
sustainability and quality and then the
outside ring here are um what is needed
to support that within the structure of
Developmental services so what is choice
mean that means that the individual has
a choice as to who will provide their
Services what services They will receive
often times maybe the staff person that
will provide
that um uniformity
means where you live should not matter
what services are offered to you that it
should be the same if I live in
Claremont I should have access to the
same services that someone in conquered
has um Quality is what we're providing
of quality are we hitting the mark are
we doing what we said we would do and
then sustainability and I think that's
where um you were kind of going
representative Edwards is are we using
the funding that is committed to to this
system is it based on actual costs can
we predict it for the future that's
sustainability um the next slide we talk
a little bit about where we've been um
and the Investments we've made in
developmental services from about 2016
to
2023 we were under Federal compliance
with a corrective action plan and I
believe we talked a little bit about
this in the last budget session um we
were out of compliance for a direct Bill
provision as well as conflict of
interest in case
management we have met this compliant um
July 1st
2023 we were found to be compliant in
both areas and so what that means is we
had a number of initiatives we wanted to
do to strengthen the system to think
about the future for individuals and
families but we couldn't get to it until
we put compliance behind us and so we
took a pause in
2024 instead of moving right towards
system strengthening of stopping and
listening to individuals and families
and the providers that support them so
we came up with shared values as to
what's important as we move forward in
the developmental Services System we had
a number of family forums we had a
number of information sessions and we
had a number of surveys that we did to
say hey what do what's important for you
as a family member as we move forward um
to strengthen the system service
providers what's important for you for
area agencies for service coordinators
we worked with everybody to make sure we
all came to agreement on what our our
values going to be moving forward and
what are the priorities that we need to
work on for the system which you will
see on your next
slide get a little sip of water
here so we came together and the four
primary areas that actually overlaid
between individuals and Families service
providers area agencies all had these
four areas in a core and that was
communication and information how do
individuals and families access
information how can we as a department
provide them with information prior to
having some of the it changes we made
the department didn't have that capacity
to communicate directly with individuals
and families we updated our website to
make it family friendly so that the
information they need is on our website
we decided that we really need to invest
in our Workforce this is an area where
it's people helping people if we don't
have the people to help the people then
people will not get services and so we
did a number of things we um using 100%
Federal homing communitybased
reinvestment funds we distributed about
15. um6 $6 million of federal funds to
help 45 organizations develop Workforce
grants to focus on retention um training
and ways to um recruit staff we also um
worked on training and development um
what type of training do providers need
so that they are able to meet the needs
of the individuals they serve and then
access to Services what is included on
our waiver how do you access the waiver
services and provided some of that
information so families understand
access of of those Workforce
Investments what what seems to be
absolutely brilliant that we're glad
we're doing it's it's so obvious it's
paying off I think there's a there's a
whole bunch of different ones and I know
um Melissa Hardy is collecting a lot of
that information but some um agencies
have done targeted recruitment like I've
seen ads on TV to try to access to
really show this is the work of a direct
support professional this is why it's
important to me other ones have invested
in training and bringing on
credentialing some of their new
Workforce so that they stay and are
invested in the organization so there's
a whole variety we can actually provide
you a summary if that would be helpful
okay and then implied in the way I
phrase that question is are there are
there any Investments we've attempted
that don't appear to be adding the value
we had hoped for and we don't need to
talk about yeah I don't know off the top
of my head but we can get that for you
all right thank
you representative Daniels thank you in
response to the uh survey that you do
yeah what's your what's your response
rate it was actually um it was
probably it was around 500 individuals
and families but that was on top of the
actual um forums that we
had okay and and it it's just something
that's put out there where someone can
go and yeah what we advertised it a
really well we um talked about it in any
of the sessions we had so we tried to
make sure people filled it out you know
um but we also did a lot of work with
having individual forums in the
different parts of the state and it was
really important and we used a location
where Department staff could be there
and to hear from families and that's
where we got a lot of really good
information in those one-on-one
you okay so our next um area is on the
next slide and it's really looking
at assessment assessment informs rate
rates as a commitment to
uniformity and so one of the things
within our developmental Services System
is we do not really have a systemic way
to match an individual's need with their
service authorization which makes it
really difficult for us to ensure that
everybody's getting the same access
based on their needs it also makes it
really difficult for us to predict our
Budget moving forward and
to use our taxpayer dollars in the way
that they were intended and so one of
the areas that we did is we had an
assessment a few years ago and um it was
shared with us that if we move towards
potentially doing assessment informed
rates where somebody's need is tied to
um the resource allocation that is a way
for greater efficiencies it creates
standardization across the state but it
also helps us predict our dollars more
effectively so we are starting to go
down that road um but as part of that we
had to develop rates and so over the
last year and a half two years we have
worked with a contractor Meyers and
stoffer to help us develop rates what is
the true cost of services based on cost
reports if you put the individual
providing the services at the center
because in developmental services and
many of our helping Services you really
need to understand what is the cost of
the worker to do the work and so we um
have had a significant stakeholder
engagement we've had about 39 to 40
different rate work groups that includes
providers individuals families um area
agencies service providers all around
looking at how would we develop
rates we have put in as a um prioritize
need in our agency budget the cost to
phase in those rates and I think
representative Edwards when you were
talking earlier um when commissioner
Tilly was presenting about you know some
of those preventative Services how we
phase in the rates if they were funded
is we are we would be starting with
those services that helps keep an
individual at home with their family so
services that help people to stay
independent and need less costly
residential services so ultimately our
goal would be by increasing those rates
making that um attractive for provid
providers to participate in more and
more people hopefully would take
advantage of some of those lower cost
Services thus delaying the need for more
costly services our goal would be over
time this would actually stabilize the
budget and not have it be um such an
year representative Daniels thank you
does the client contribute to the cost
the client um covers their own room and
board um they cover some of their
spending money um some of their other
benefits but aside from that we build
Services representative Stringham so
these uh these rates are all within the
uh developmental disability waiver is
that correct and and are they similar to
any other services or any other Medicaid
Program so how if if were to get these
rates we would then put them into the
Medicaid waiver as part of our work to
develop the rates you have to ensure
parity with other services that are
similar in another part of Medicaid okay
thank you um the um are you finding
anywhere where uh the rates
are generous or is everything kind of
um more likely to be increased in cost
than than then decrease yeah there
wouldn't be a
decrease thank you but I guess the
I there wouldn't be a decrease in the
rates but if when we move and Implement
if we are able to the assessment and
form rates we are going we have we would
better be able to align with what a
person's assessed need is with the
service authorization they reive we
don't have that mechanism today so I
can't say that okay if these were to be
funded you would see a change
immediately but I do believe you would
see a change over
time I I I think what you would also see
um as Chris had alluded to earlier is
less
variability um and I think in the long
run too when it comes to when it comes
to the budget accuracy is really
important so that you don't over budget
and by having more standardized rates
that would allow us to budget more
accurately so so maybe you would have
extra money or money that you wouldn't
need to budget because you you you'd
have a higher level of assurity there
that could be used elsewhere so it's
it's not necessarily only the question
of are you going to spend less but are
you going to budget what you're going to
spend I think is really key there and
that's been that's been one of the
challenges
historically um be uh because we have to
reserve that money right corre for this
program yes thank you so so I'm looking
at the the fourth block there where it's
it's got the bullet that says uh with
budget approval and I'm thinking about
what I think I heard you say when when
you said that you in order to do the
rate phase in you may need some
additional money and it and that
additional money will show up probably
in a prioritized need yes okay so so
when the time is right I'd like to
really understand why you need money to
do a rate phas in okay I think Melissa
will definitely include that in her
budget presentation but we can also sit
down and review that if you'd like yeah
because simp my simple thought is you
just you take this rate and you turn it
this way and take this rate and turn it
this way and then boom you've got your
rate adjustment and that didn't cost you
anything okay so it's got to be more
complex but don't forget when we develop
these rates we actually receive cost
reports from providers we worked with
providers to say what is the cost for
direct support professional so some of
these rates we would look to phase in
early haven't been looked at for years
all right so we we have something to
look forward to there yes you do yes sir
I I think one important thing
particularly for new members um when we
are when we are talking about the DD
budget there's three accounts and for
the current bium it's total funds of
about $900 million so so when you are
looking at the HHS budget I think it's
just important to recognize that this is
a large portion so when you make
adjustments to a rate here or there when
we're talking about um you know this
area being a large um a large dollar
amount that that will have impacts um to
areas okay so that's developmental
services so before I move on to healthy
aging do you have any other questions I
I do I I would you would you feel
comfortable hearing the DD Community the
DD part of this budget
described as the part of the budget that
uh attempts to address the needs of New
Hampshire's most vulnerable
citizens I I would say individuals with
disabilities are some of New Hampshire's
most vulnerable citizens yes all right
okay so now we're g to move on to health
go for so um healthy aging if you see
this first slide this is demographics as
to why do we need to focus on healthy
aging as a state um New Hampshire is one
of the SEC is the second oldest state in
the country not as as long as we've been
here but
demographically um and nearly 20% of New
Hampshire's population is age 65 and
over and 35% of our population is age 55
and over and so um it behooves us as a
state to focus on how do we support
those that are older adults to age in
place at home receive the services they
need at home and delay any further more
extensive um services and so in um the
last budget we received um funding and a
charge to develop a system of care for
healthy aging and really what that
system of care of healthy aging which is
described on the visualized on the next
slide is a comprehensive and coordinated
system of care that promotes healthy
aging and enables adults who are older
and adults with disabilities have
meaning full choice and care options in
their homes and in their communities and
if you look at this little visual here
this is the vision for the system of
care for healthy aging and it's not just
what the Department of Health and Human
Services is using as a visual it's also
what this um State Commission on Aging
is using what the alliance for healthy
aging is using so that we're all working
together with a common goal and if you
look at the Outer Circle there's a
number of services and supports and some
of these services are preventative in
nature and so I think about the meals
and nutrition programs in 2024 through
the department 15,000 people received
Meals on Wheels in the state of those
15,000 people 61% of them said that was
their primary source of nutrition for
the day and also of those 15,000
41% said the driver who delivered their
meals was the only person they saw
during the day so again it's one of
those social programs that has a focused
area but it does such good to support
older adults in our state we also have
in this Outer Circle abuse NE and
neglect um prevention and we do that in
the department through our Adult
Protective Services Program which is um
authorized under RSA 161 and it really
ensures that vulnerable adults are not
subject to abuse neglect and
exploitation and so you see how some of
these services in the Outer Circle and
we use a combination of funding whether
it's state general funds whether it's
old age assist
whether it's older American act dollars
Administration for Community Living to
really wrap services around somebody and
then as you go into the green part of
the circle those are locations that
maybe is out of a person's home and so
that the services on the outside weren't
enough to keep somebody at home so then
we needed more um Services whether
that's through our nursing facilities or
waiver some of the work on the system of
care has also helped us to ensure what
you will see on the next slide is um
made we had to make some Financial
eligibility changes made it a little bit
easier for people to access access
Medicaid services we got rid of the
spousal impoverishment which basically
means that previously if you had a
member a spouse that was living at home
they had to actually become impoverished
for their spouse to get services and we
changed that knowing that that's really
not the right thing to do um who who is
we it was actually the state of New
Hampshire as outlined in um hb2 last
year so so that's an hb2 item so it's
law now is that ongoing continuing law
or was that just for the continued yes
okay um we increased the resource
disregards um we also change the look
back period so prior to hb2 if you
applied for Medicaid you had to provide
60 months of financial documents so
think of yourself if you are trying to
help a family member um to come up with
60 months of documents that you may not
even know um accounts that your parent
may have had so with and that was a
barrier for people to access services
and so through hb2 with the system of
care we're allowed to go back 36 months
as long as if we do we do these data
scans through um a verification system
as long as there aren't any red flags we
can go ahead with a 36 months which
really helps people get access to
Services
quicker represent Daniels on the
Medicaid Eligibility is isn't it still 5
years to to get connected to Med
Medicaid on the look back period we've
switched that to 36 months as long as
there isn't when we do our um scans
through the databases that it doesn't
look like there was a transfer of assets
so if something is a red flag we will go
and look beyond the 36 months but for
the majority of people it's 36 months is
there a federal uh eligibility
requirement that people have to buy into
we had we received Federal approval to
do the
36 um month Lookout I'm just wondering
if somewhere along the line there there
isn't different
qualifications 36 months for the state
or 60 for the federal it's we we're
allowed to do the 36 months with the
federal appr understand what you're
saying okay I'm asking is it still a
requirement federally of of five years
so so when the law was written um in hb2
they amended RSA
1674 and in the in the state law it said
to the extent permissible F by federal
law where they changed it from 60 to 36
months and we've since received approval
So currently it is compli
it
okay anything okay um we also um were
required to do a choices for
Independence rate study to look at the
rates um for our choices for independent
services to make sure they're
competitive to keep people at home we um
made a number of changes and are still
working on the changes to New Hampshire
easy which is our gateway to Services um
to ensure that individuals their
caregivers um and families can actually
access through our provider portal and
we've been able to use 100% Federal
funding to enhance um New Hampshire easy
and finally we expanded who could be a
provider of personal care
that okay so I'm going to move now into
our home and Community Based waivers
that's
okay under the division of long-term
supports and services we have four home
and community- based waivers these are
1915c waivers they are
voluntary um we have to um show in the
aggregate of the waiver that it is cost
neutral so that the average cost is less
on the waiver than it is in an
institution um that is required by
CMS we have four different waivers we
have the children's inhome support
waiver and that is for children birth
through the age of 21 they must live at
home with their families um and they
have to still be in school for this
service it is family directed which
means the families really direct how the
services occur in their home and all of
the services are based out of the
person's home we have our developmental
disability waiver which is our largest
waiver and that is primarily um those
who have exited the school system and
that's where some someone will receive
day Services residential respit
Employment Services to remain
independent and then we have our
acquired brain disorder service um
waiver and that's for those ages 22 to
60 so that I know it's confusing right
so that means that their brain injury
had to occur after the age of 22 if it
occurred before that age then they would
be served under the developmental
disability waiver because that would be
considered a developmental disability
because it occurred while you were
developing and then it ends at age 60
because then you would go under the
choices for Independence waiver and then
we have our choices for Independence
waiver any questions on
these okay sorry I have a quick question
can you just explain to me the the
average cost per year column and what
those figures mean yep so if for for the
$460 children on the inhome support
waiver the average cost is about
$14,000 that um waiver is capped at
35,000 so it cannot exceed that
amount developmental disability we serve
just under 6,000 people and that average
cost is $73,000
um there are a high number of
residential services on the DD waiver
which actually makes the cost go up that
is one of the areas when we talked
earlier about the rate work that we want
to get standardization and uniformity to
costs
okay repr Str yeah and then how many in
the other two programs so on the
acquired brain disorder we serve about
235 people and for CFI about 39,000 I
mean 3900
sorry and um you just in in digging into
the rates is there any you know um um
you know my understanding of the way
these things work is this is a service
somebody needs and this is how much it
costs and I can imagine that there are
services in there that are relatively
inexpensive that they may find extremely
valuable and ones that cost more that
you know maybe they don't feel as
strongly about is there any ability
Within These waiver
programs uh to tailor them somewhat so
that the um you know the cost to the
state may be lower but the value to the
recipient would be higher I think that's
where we were looking at some of the
rate work and when Melissa presents um
later this month or early next month she
can kind of go over some of those but we
really want to incentivize or encourage
um some of the services the rates that
keep people at home keep people
independent and right now those rates
are really low but we think there's
great value to them because the longer
somebody can stay independent stay with
their family live on their own then
they're going to need less Residential
definitely representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions back on page 15
again the number of people that you have
been able to provide service in home inh
home supports what was that oh sorry
that was
460 Children and Families okay and what
about developmental disability um
welcome so um one of the ways questions
I think you had prior to us presenting
is how do we measure performance and I
know Meredith tus um was here talking
about the division of program quality
quality and integrity and so there's
many ways that we partner actually with
um that division within the department
so you take the program staff who really
understand the program you take the
program quality and integrity that
understand quality and working together
how do we ensure the services we provide
are quality and that we're doing um what
the individuals and families need so we
have a variety of ways that we measure
performance um I won't go over all of
them you have them on your slides but
because we have a Medicaid waiver um we
have to provide certain financial and
service quality assurances to um the
center for Medicare and Medicaid
services we do file reviews we do
governance audits we have providers
report adverse um incidents that happen
and then we have follow up to make sure
that doesn't happen again and the
incident was corrected um through
developmental Services we use the
national core indicators which actually
measures a person's experience receiving
Services because that's really important
to understand um and then we just
started doing that for the Bureau of
aging and adult Services um we also make
sure that services are provided as
authorized was there an authorization
before a service was um claimed and then
um were the actions taken
resolved
questions yes so uh thanks for taking my
question thank you um on slide 15 so
just so just so I'm
clear this is uh uh represent what what
year this is fiscal year 24 fiscal year
24 and the same kind of a question the
the numbers that you have here are they
relatively stable over a period of years
or they increasing decreasing in these
categories or is that something I can
find um we
do you will start to see on the fiscal
dashboard the developmental Services
numbers we had to take a break because
we had some it system changes the the
acquired brain disorder population stays
pretty consistent um the children's
inhome support is also pretty consistent
because we just a a limited amount of
services where you'll see growth um is
through developmental Services because
as kids leave the school system then
they need Services right so we always
have a feeder to towards the services
and then for choices for Independence
we've seen a little bit of growth over
the years and our goal is to continue to
grow that
you 18 now um I think I am so we're
going to talk about financing and um
Nursing Facility but I did want to
answer representative Daniel's question
from when we did the overview you asked
about Nursing Facility um eligibility um
and so typically what happens is if
somebody is determined that they would
like to go to a nursing home they need
to go into nursing home um they usually
start with the financial eligibility
first because that is the most
extensive then once that is close to
being resolved then we do the medical
assessment to make sure you're meeting
that level of care sometimes we can do
it at the same time depends what's going
on usually families come with a facility
in mind or then that's when they start
to look for facilities to see who may
have an available bed often times a
nursing facility until someone has
Medicaid isn't going to want to accept
the person because they need them to
have Medicaid so once the person has
Medicaid once the nursing facility says
yes we have a bed we can take this
person then we do a change of status
form that then tells the department the
nursing facility submits that so then
the department knows it's okay to bill
servicee great
um so we were asked to provide a high
level overview of the financing um for
the nursing facilities and choices for
Independence program accounting unit
2152 this is a really important one and
and part of the reason that we want to
talk about this early is you're going to
see this again but it's not the most
straightforward um funding mechanism and
I think it's really important to
understand um so accounting into at 2152
uh for this year I think we're at about
$380 million so this is a single
accounting unit and it pays for a couple
of key Services number one is the
choices for Independence program is it
paid it's paid out of that out of class
506 and this is not the first time or
this is not the last time we're going to
talk about this I'm sure and then
there's also the nursing home payment
line that's class 504 and what that
represents is it represents the payments
um for Medicaid eligible individuals
that are in nursing facilities within
the state and the slide before you shows
uh how how the funding mix Works in in
New Hampshire um so there's a federal
match it's approximately 50% and you'll
see the the blue uh the blue piece of
the pie there that's the federal funds
now there's also a portion of that that
are state general funds and then there's
also County funds and we're going to
talk about this more but we're talking
about the county cap and RSA 1671
18a within that stat statute there is
the county cap and what that is it's
basically a fixed dollar amount that the
legislature every 2 years determines
that this is going to be the amount that
the counties will contribute towards um
these CFI and Nursing Facility
payments and um typically that that's
adjusted by hb2 I don't know if it's
ever been adjusted else in other in any
other piece of legislation but you'll
see that show up in hb2 and I'm sure
once the governor's budget comes out
we'll have an opportunity to go over
that section there's also a credit in
statute the credit by default is $5
million and in certain years that credit
has been increased and other years it's
been slightly lower so I think it's been
as high as $1 million and I think maybe
as low as three I can't recall up my
head and so what you'll end up seeing in
the actual accounting unit is you will
not see the county cap figure in the
accounting unit what you will see is
you'll see the county cap figure plus
with the credit applied so it'll be
about $5 million less um there was also
an element of Statute that was added a
few years ago that limits the growth of
the county cap by 2% each year what we
found though in the past couple of years
is we have seen expenses moving at a
higher rate than just 2% so you will see
when you do um I I if if you do look at
the agency budget that was previously
submitted you will see the those General
funds increasing at a fairly High rate
um certain certainly not at at a 2% rate
by any means because the cost of care um
in in the medical field has um seen some
pretty high inflation over the past
couple of years so that's a very high
level overview of this I don't know how
deep you want to go I have handouts if
you want to take 15 or 20 minutes or we
can pick it up another day and touch on
services let's look at your uh graphic
that you want to hand out and then uh
just take we'll just look at it real
quick and we'll get a sense of I'll get
a sense of whether or not we should go
into the detail sure it's it's a
two-page detailed
explanation okay if if we want to go
through that let's hand it out give
people a chance to read it and then um
the next time you come in to talk about
this subject well we should be better
and and so I think this may come close
to getting ready to conclude what we're
going to do and I uh commissioner Weaver
I see you back there do you do you do
you want to say anything I I want to
give you the the privilege of saying
something if you want about what we've
whatever yeah no you can't hide they
they were all pointing at you earlier do
you want to use the microphone at the
table thank you thank you for the
opportunity I don't have anything
further to add right now but thank you
okay well thank you for
coming uh representative yeah have one
quick question uh Mr White yeah uh
thanks uh for the presentation and
looking at the pie charts uh on the
county funding is that an a you is that
the same for all counties or is that an
average or sure so the the reason that I
handed out a two-page detail explanation
is be because that starts to get down in
the details there what we do is we look
at a three-year history of medic
simplistically a three-year history of
Medicaid claims and then there's a
little bit more to it but basically it's
proportionally divied out to the
counties and there's intergovernmental
agreements between the department and
each County um that go through GNC that
are approved and we receive a monthly
payment um from the
county so just my understanding it could
the amounts county by county would be
pretty ver this isn't a is a pretty
lumpy distribution it's on page two yeah
it's it's on the second page um you'll
see Hillsboro County uh really handles
the bulk of it um and it's significantly
higher than you know Sullivan or or
Grafton County or others and again
that's based on the actual Medicaid
cleans over three-year period okay thank
you if I had looked at the asked the
question thanks all right do do you have
concluding remarks associate
commissioner santanella now I just want
to say thank you um for your time um
your flexibility and when I was able to
present I hope you're feeling better I
feel a lot better thank you very much
but I'm still glad you're beyond
contagious disease yes I am not
contagious right now good Mr White do
you have any concluding remarks you'd
like to make um no uh I I think um we
will have going back to the conversation
that we had earlier around the the
budget books and the presentations we
will be bringing forward a three- ring
binder um and what we'll be bringing at
each presentation we'll be bringing the
the presentation that has the accounting
unit strings the programmatic detail and
we'll also have the budget briefing
books um which which again I if if you
have a chance I encourage you to take a
look at on the lb's website those are
really a mountain of information for
each area and they try to get out all
the details um that that we were talking
about earlier for some of these programs
so hopefully we can address that in
advance and if you do have any questions
in advance please please send them along
so we can prepare those before we get
those uh before we get to the
presentations or if there's any
particular topics that we haven't
discussed that you kind of want to hear
a little bit more about all right um
from the committee are there any
questions for the Department um in the
audience is there is there any member of
the public that wishes to say
anything uh yes sir um why don't you sit
at the end
here and that way you can use that
microphone and we'll just need to make
record and the mic Goes On by hitting
the button and it goes red there you go
all right thank you very much um members
of the committee my name is Jeb cup I'm
with life coping we're a case management
agency um we cover the uh whole state of
New Hampshire we work on both the CFI or
choices for Independence waiver and also
on the developmental disabilities waiver
um acquired brain disorder and um inh
home support waiver so um this was
really a great presentation now we were
particularly interested in Chris Sant
Neo's presentation and really appreciate
all of the the numbers and the hard work
in this um one thing that has been
discussed or earlier um was the the rate
the lack of rates and from the case
management perspective when we look at
um for instance the choices for
Independence waiver um and other waivers
um the rates in the U CFI waiver that we
have um if you know what popped out at
me was that when you look at the average
cost I I realize all these are different
populations they're all unique they all
have unique needs and we we have to of
course take that into um utmost
consideration um we've got with the CFI
waivers about
$25,000 I think it's it's useful for the
the committee to know that these
individuals have a nursing home level of
care so they are eligible to be in a
nursing home um at significantly greater
cost cost so that's about
$75,000 so if you look at they're kept
in the community um or they're
maintained or they're um participating
in the community at $225,000 a year so
it's it's really there's a
$50,000 um actual um savings for the
state and the federal government and the
counties by having these individuals in
the um in the choices for Independence
waiver um the
one other thing that jumped out um and
that was discussed and is is so
important is the um establishment of of
rates um we find or our case managers
find it's very difficult without having
standardized rates in our DD waiver um
to um um basically predict anything as
the um the um CFO for the for DHHS said
um we have some clients in DD I have um
we have one with life coping who has an
almost
$700,000 a year budget so that's for 12
months um it's $670,000
um
and um all those rates have to be just
really just pounded out um by uh the
case managers by the state um by um
sometimes the um the DRC will get
involved it's a very complicated process
and the um the benefit to all involved
the state the federal government of
course the the the participants in the
program of having these standardized AES
standardized rates would be would be
hugely important um I think in getting a
handle on this and if you look at I I
just went through and did some quick
math um we've got about uh 5,900 people
in DD waiver and if you multiply that by
the the number here it's about $500
million if if you look at the CFI waiver
um you've got 3,900 individuals in there
um at
$25,000 so it's it's just shy of a
hundred million so you're talking and
again we have to always remember each of
these populations are are uniquely
different they have very different needs
and but just by looking at numbers
you're seeing 5 to one in CFI we're
seeing $100
million um for 3,900 people now we got
about 6,000 people in DD if if we were
going to compare apples to apples um and
have 6,000 in CFI that's about a 50%
rough math increase so you're talking
about $150 million to service 6,000
people um where we've got um a half a
billion dollar or a half a billion
dollars to now service um about 6,000
people under the DD waiver so I I just
wanted to um to mention that and um
thank um thank you all for the
opportunity to
speak don't don't don't go away because
I might if you'll let me I want to ask
you a couple questions um but but first
um when we're talking about rates I just
want to keeping I I just want to know if
I'm thinking about this right the rates
that we want to adjust to I believe are
the Alvarez and Marcel two rate system
to and and we want to implement that
structured system system into what we're
are no no so so so let's save that okay
I just want if I were right I would have
just kept going because but I'm not
right so you need to educate me and
that's going to take time um but I
forget your name Jeb cop Jeb okay Jeff
um so thank you for being willing to
take a a question since you're out in
the community one of the things I've
I've I've wondered about and given that
we I I
think you know any fool could wander in
here and realize the CFI program is a
great program and we should be doing the
CFI as much as we possibly can the
concern that I think we have in all of
our our service provision is whether or
not we have the capacity do are are you
able with your Workforce issues able to
scale your Your Capacity so you can
support significantly more people in a
environment yeah that's a great question
um I think right now and I think some of
there's another uh Granite case
management is here as well they may want
to speak to this um there's always a
lack of providers um there always has
been and and maybe there always will but
it used to be much better um I know in
the southern part of the State uh
clients would have a uh a option of five
different agencies to choose from for
their services um now that's no longer
the case in the southern part of the
state we're scrambling um to find
service providers um the same way that
people are I think it's most acute in in
the northern in Coos and Grafton
counties um up in Berlin and the
Northern parts of the state um but I I
think you know it's another thing it's
it's it's a question of supply and
demand that's why the rate said is so
important and how do you and it's always
at some point the the demand is going to
shift and increase as as the rates
increased um and um so I I would say
that that that whole part about um
having well we're speaking about CFI for
CFI we've got to look at the rates all
the time because we're we're certainly
not where we were um preco in terms of
providers there's with got less
providers than we had before Co and it
it things got really um pretty bad
during Co but it's it has improved but
um I think it's a question to answer
your question if if we consistently look
at the the the rate setting and the
methodology for rate setting um will'll
be able to manage that supply and demand
and put more people um who who would
like to be into CFI and the CFI all
right thank you did you have a comment I
just um kind of to support what um Jeb
um shared and thank you Jeb was um last
session when the legislature did
appropriate funding for rate increases
and I don't have the data in front of me
but I do have it um we met with two um
CFI providers Waypoint and asentria and
they shared with us the impact of those
rate increases they were able to get
staff who wanted to stay working there
but left due to the wages come back to
entria and Waypoint to work with
individuals they were able to add I want
to say like 140 hours a month of
services they were able to eliminate
their weight lless so the rate increase
does matter and how we went about it for
the choices for Independence waiver and
for um the developmental disability
waiver is starting at the cost of the
direct support work what does it cost to
recruit and retain and I do think that
over time if we are able to have stable
rates um it will enhance the ability of
providers to serve these vulnerable
populations I I saw a hand in the
audience
u m Miss virtue Jeff if you if you want
to sit there still you can we got lots
virtue thank you for the introduction Mr
chairman carollyn virtue Granite case
management I would like to reiterate
that the rate increases from last year
have significantly
impacted our ability to fill
authorized services in the care plans
the providers that Miss sanon ELO
mentioned are Personal Care Service
Agency providers and um that
information um is very good since I
wasn't going to come up but since now up
I did have one other thing that I wanted
to mention um in the system of care
language that was passed last year um
case
management was
specifically um mentioned as not to be
um in the um
CFI Navigator or provider groups and
that wasn't made clear today and that is
important
because um the CFI case
management is a state plan
service so when that um rate is um being
scored it should be scored against like
services and to date it has not
been that's it for me well you beat me
because I I have almost no idea what
you're talking about so so thank you for
that do do you have a comment on from
the Department no I I think we're okay I
think what Carolyn was just trying to
show is in the developmental disability
waivers those that Service Coordination
is part of the waiver and for choices
for independent it's an state plan
service that's serves the waiver
population all
right okay um you have any further
comment no I'll see you when you have
your coloring book though okay good good
all right um so I'm not seeing any more
people in the audience wanting to say
something and I think the Department's
done uh committee's done so I'll end
with you Mr Ripple like I try to usually
usually do what what what what's what's
next on our dance card well I'm just
going to work with Nathan to come up
with a schedule of agency presentation
starting next Tuesday and um I'll
discuss that with you privately first
committee okay that's that sounds good
so so thank you for coming up with a
draft on the calendar and we we just had
some thoughts that Mr rip will share
with you on that all right um well with
that I think uh I think we've covered a